bismillah al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be with you I'm Eddie your host
you're watching the Dean show and we're
here at our future home a home that
awaits us all from the womb and then to
the tomb and in between it's what we do
in this life that's going to determine
if we're going to be successful in the
next life or not so the young man who's
in his grave his life was taken he was
murdered and in this episode of the Dean
show we're going to find out why what
happened how did this 19 year old boy
who was a undefeated wrestler who was
young strong athletic good family and at
the blink of an eye his life his whole
life changed and now he's in the grave
his life is finished so stay tuned we
come back we're going to find out why
what happened and how you can get
involved to help police track down the
criminal that did this and bring him to
justice be right back with sameer bark a
story here on the dicho this is the
thing the beach
this is the things is the teacher this
is the thesis bethine jus
the needle this is the angel miss
malotte hamdulillah Salaam alaikum peace
be with few greetings of peace to
everybody all around the world I was
turning into the Dean show we started
off we took you to a scene at the
graveyard and we had expressed that this
is a home that all of us one day
tomorrow to date in a year in a second
we can end up in and we want to make the
best out of this light before we visit
our future home the grave but a young
man's life sadly was taken away 19 years
old and this young man was your son i'm
here with with our brother your brother
Baraka how are you sir I hamdulillah
Salaam alaikum alaikum salam ala have to
lock thank you for finding the courage
you know the energy to be with us you
know here on the Dijon thank you you're
welcome we really thought it'd be really
important to create awareness so we can
get our brothers and sisters from all
around the globe now people are tuning
in to the Dean show from all over and
some if this just goes away people
forget so now we're going to have people
from all over making dua for your family
and in sha Allah this culprit the
criminal get brought to justice and the
police will go inshallah get some tips
that we can you know have this
individual in jail so he's not out there
hurting killing another innocent human
being so tell us now you were coming
from tell us what happened me and my two
sons was basically coming from a night
out you know as we was bonding we tell
stories telling jokes and so on and we
make it home we come through this way
the alley and I got felt that to ask us
questions are we
and again are we lacking and repeatedly
three times you said no no and we don't
get bang and he said yeah better dip I
started shooting at us I was able to
push one of my kids to the side behind
the dumpster and take the other one put
him in front of me but yet after a full
shot I think he was shot at the fourth
shot and dropped on the floor and there
was one more shot after that you
mentioned when we spoke yesterday that
you had gotten home you you you were you
know we're fasting his Foreman on so
people know that we begin our day before
the break of dawn eat a little bit and
then we don't need that's what he was
saying as we was right there he said he
looked at his watch is what is that's
where it was hit we have enough time to
do so hood to beat me in a video game
and do frigid and go to sleep that was
his last words so you guys didn't say
nothing to the guy as he was talking me
and my son Sammy the one that was
responding to him that we not gang
members we basically we will say no we
nominate would not in the gang your
son's don't have anything to do with a
game my son is sweetheart his athletic
he's he achieved like some medals and
football black say medals and wrestling
bikes and medals in tracks fourth and
sixth place and tracks first and second
place on Chicago in wrestling and
football least calm Julia's pepper
that's how good he was and football so
you had gotten to the front I remember
you mentioned you gone to the front of
your house to the front and then you
ended up coming around because you just
wanted to kill some more time to come
around what was it we would just didn't
finish the jokes that we were selling
each other and the stories father and
sons bonding right so you want some more
bonding time exactly yes
so easy we was thinking that we can use
another couple of minutes so we can
finish the stories we tell him the jokes
and he tells good jokes he is type of
person that anybody that met him within
3-4 sentence he'll tell you a joke or a
joke of something that he did he'll make
you laugh so you which are two sons
you're walking down this alley okay you
guys get the shot you're walking down
this alley it's family time you're
spending time with your family your two
sons and now you guys are heading
towards the back door ok 5 feet 25 feet
away ok and then you hear this
individual now the criminal who shot
your son heels what did he yell out hey
are y'all kinks now what's this Kings I
mean what is that a gang that's
basically dominating this neighborhood
is three gangs and two more Yanks trying
to move in or they already in ok there's
kings there is kg boys so these will say
I mean these are people that are
striking terror in the neighborhood
innocent people are trying to get to
work you know live their lives
productive citizens so these people come
and are starting to strike terror into
the people such as you don't know if
he's the king or if he's from the other
game because he's asking us are you king
and we say no and he still shot so so
you had clearly told him look we have
nothing to do with any gangs or any
affiliation with any games they have
that long of a conversation yeah I just
said no the second question he has the
second time my son says no we don't
gangbang the third question I looked I
was like no man that's when he pulled
the gun he said some of what he said you
better dip dip you better did that's
like slang for run run and then the
shots rang out yes and then you end up
now we see what we're here you can see
take the camera to have a look over here
we have the pool of blood so is this
where now that's what he dropped on his
face and that's what I thought he was
taking cover and I was able to jump on
top of him so he don't get shot and I'm
looking back there the guys about 125
feet hundred thirty
feet away you know and he turns around
and run and my son Sammy sees the blood
and he started yelling son his brother
named Samir Samir so when I looked and I
saw the blood I told him go get a phone
call 911 and he did and I turned Samir
around and listened to his heart beat
and it was beating so I start calling
him like come on Samir and he was not
moving for about 10 minutes he did not
move at all though Samir Sammy came back
with the phone his mom or dare came back
with the phone sister everybody the
neighbors and start coming out called
911 it was a gather and here's the
shooter but yeah everybody can all the
neighbors everybody's out at this point
yes 10 minutes after that and that's he
started gagging on his blood they start
gagging on his blood and I turned him to
his side he's in your arms no yes yes
turn on my side the blood came out I see
the blood coming out of everywhere in
his face and but he had not responded
yet his first response he had bull his
hand on the ground and he tried to get
up so at this point I don't want to pull
it to travel so I'm trying to hold him
down I end up on my back on the floor
and he's on top of me and I held him and
wrestling move that I told him and he
won several times with that move and I
held him that way with my arms and my
legs so he don't move and he was still
too strong for me you know right did I
start telling Sammy to go and get the
car he got the keys from his mom and
went to get the car because the
ambulance was taking too long picked him
up try to put him in the car he just
bought a car not too long ago and he
didn't fit in the backseat of it so now
the ambulance say it just you you you
you're feeling that time is crucial I'm
special so now you get the your car try
to get him in the car
this one fit no and I was I was trying
to vote him in there we saw the
ambulance comes in an alley and they
missed the early and by time did he
turned around I come to this side it was
police cars everywhere where the
ambulance couldn't come through so when
the stretcher came ambulance people
couldn't even pick him up from there
because he's holding on to me everything
I'm the one that put him on a stretcher
roll to the stretcher brimming ambulance
then his mom sister and two little
brother followed as me and Sammy stayed
back because we had to give her the
information to the police they won't let
us leave after we're done it was like
almost shook son is about to come out
and that's a little before that that's
what my wife called me and said the
doctor said that he's not gonna make it
he won't make it more than 24 hours I
told her just go read some put onto him
say Laila hang on law and that's what he
did it what she did a soon as I got done
I went in to the hospital and I kept
reading Quran to him and I'm knowing
that I'm losing my son and doctors tried
to convince me like this is it and I
said try to do your best you said he
don't he won't make it 24 hour let's do
that 24 hour let's prepare their family
because I won't know what to go and tell
my daughter and my other sons that y'all
lost their brothers you know so it was
around seven clock when the doctor says
the blood pressure is too low it was 35
/ 13 and there was a medication that
they can use they can put in there where
you can increase the blood pressure and
if it doesn't work then they're going to
have to put another tube in him and that
will work
so the medication did not work but the
tube did work and has that blood
pressure was increasing the harpy was
dropping and it was dropping fast I
stepped out the room just for a few
seconds not even a minute you know just
to go and check on the kids and come
back and as I'm running back to the room
and I'm hearing my life crying you know
I probably got there monitor was saying
like 10 heartbeats you know and I'm not
even around the curtain you know I'm
just peeking to see what's going on
moniteau said 10 heartbeats and the
nurse says who's going to pronounce the
death and the doctor says 930 we
pronounced him dead so now yeah we just
did the right thing said the red the
Shahada for him I don't know whether is
that accepted or not why did they say
that I had an outside on Samir since
he's not able to talk I kept reading
what are so this all could come out
easily I know you use you've told the
story over and over and you've said so
many tears and it's been a very
emotional time in your life and made the
creator of the heavens and earth make it
easy for you and your family and I I
want you to tell us for the person have
have the police been able to so far we
know that they haven't caught this
individual I don't know they kahramana
last conversation I had with the
detective less than 24 hours ago they
said they have several people there only
two that they call with the same gun
that my son was shot with what kind of
gun was he shot with it was a 45 caliber
Smith & Wesson with the Winchester
bullets any advice that you have for
families who they have their kids
they're alive
and kids who have their parents of
families now they've never tasted
something like this you know to really
reflect about the purpose of life and to
take life seriously and you know what
advice do you have that's exactly what
it is life is precious you know it's not
ours vice precious spend it wisely you
know basically keep them around you I
mean the Allah is the protector is only
is the only protector you cannot protect
anybody you cannot protect yourself to
protect others so keep your faith in
Allah the same time bond with your kids
no matter what matter if they one year
old or if the 30 40 years old keep
bonding with them because you don't know
when you're gonna go or when they can I
go he having missed not one Ramadan
since the age of seven fast all her
Madonna's I probably missed couple of
days here there or a few days if I
mistake and so on he have not missed one
day from done he makes sure he fast on
Roman art and that's his friends on the
basketball court used to pick on him
like why are you fasting it was like why
are you not fasting there was like cuz
it's too hard he was like you could get
it one day you'll get it and if they
push him to get him angry he'll get fall
he'd get up after they took the ball
from him and he'll go and take the ball
make that basket and he still smile and
it was like you don't get angry I was
like why should I we playing i just paid
i'd like to thank you and may the
creator of the heavens and earth
continue to make things easy for you to
reward you for all your patience and
send mercy and blessings upon your
family may you or night reunite you with
your son anjana shirt on brother thank
you thank you oh yeah
so lonely okay you got your dream home
and you've got your dream car but you're
going to get old and things are going to
happen to you in your life and then what
have you got at the end of the day is an
empty dream that has no real foundation
we are going to die and we're going to
meet our Lord and he is going to judge
us it becomes an obligation for each
single human being to find out what the
Quran is Islam is telling us to stay
away from things which are bad for your
person in bed for the society one God
wish him alone do what he wants you to
do put your desires this thing inside
you that just wants this and wants that
and you just can't get enough you know
what you'll never get enough until the
dirts in your mouth don't let it come to
that be sincere and honest as the one
who created you to guide you is the
first step put off chasing all the women
and the good times and the parties and
this and that there is no one would be a
voice it except a lot don't wait you
never know his death will come today for
you're not deaf and the day of judgment
the mercy of Allah these are the things
that finally made me realize there is no
time to delay anymore I want you to take
martial heart of right there great the
essence of spirituality is to become
were sincere to Las planetary fun to
play death itself it is very very scary
but it brings you back to reality there
is a life which is everlasting and if
you and you have to make a conscious
decision of which a group of people do
you want to be off believe I'm having
other people of help Allah peace be unto
you were here with the butter cut family
and it's a very for me you know usually
people are turning in watching the Dean
show and I'm very elated and excited and
you know we're sharing the message of
the purpose of life and I heard this
story and I just couldn't let it pass by
because I didn't want this you know we
got people dying all over the world and
this is something I just happened in our
backyard this story brought us together
and I didn't want it to just be a fading
memory I wanted to get this story out
there to humanity so we can make a
difference so we can try to help
stop another innocent human being from
tomorrow you know getting killed in a
senseless violence so we got to hear
what happened to your son this is your
brother I'd better get so I'm alaikum
peace be with you all I concern are the
love again you flew in from California
what were your thoughts when you heard
this the last thing in your wildest
imagination you wouldn't think you were
getting a call what tell us at that
moment what happened actually some
lahore him I when I just wake up just
the time different i wake up text
somebody just text me a message i read
it says semi-urban use of just died
that's your nephew now yeah said
semi-urban news have died who crazy used
who's crazy sending this message may be
a joke yeah a look it's my sister i told
my wife Samir Samir just died so her son
so she is Samir opening sohail my son is
Yusuf Samir Samir been so he'll so my
wife crashed start crying I don't
believe what's going on so I called my
sister my sister my sister she said yeah
he just passed away it's just hit you
when I was wondering what the hey what's
going on it's is it real is it is it
sickness is shot what's going on then I
called her she said no he got shot so I
start I talk your telephone number I
called him and he was crying he said
just got shot just got shot so I just
get the first plane and fly all the way
yeah one-way ticket all the way to
Chicago yeah that's the I you just got
to one-way ticket I said I just want to
go see what's going on because was
really surprising something like this
happen you always see it in news you see
it everywhere I thought
some-something friend or something but
like mascara like this when you hear it
and everywhere you never thought you'd
go into hit home once its head home is
totally different you're not going to
flip channels anymore you will hear what
other people say a lot of people they
look at the TV 11 people together just
get died this guy in theater this here
this year in serious people get killed
you just look at it and would call the
plot you just keep flipping channels
that's I'm one of them so I just keep
flipping the channel flipping the
channels and forget that there's really
there's human life just get lost and we
don't even think about that we just
thinking about the remote control just
okay go now another killing here now I
don't are killing here that's what
really it's going start hitting you now
it's home so how we going to deal with
it how have you guys been dealing with
it so far how are you guys holding up so
far we're trying to gather together all
of us from California came in from New
York from Ohio came in too much to join
my brother to make sure that make all I
make it easier on all of us and on him
and and I told them anything happened we
have to get deposit of out of it it's
easy he killed my son I'm going to grab
a gun and go around somebody else to
kill to kill that killed us but what
about if we can get something positive
out of it the positive thing is start
try to make awareness for everybody we
try to catch those people try to stop
them from what they're doing what we go
what like I told him there's a Lara
agency they could help to do some flyers
or do some reward for them and when
we're in cemetery we you mentioned and
we were about the crime stopper and
yesterday we called and we find out
about some information and we want to do
some fly
we want to do something on their school
we want to do some some more stuff to
gather people to tell them this is
really did hit home and you guys really
need to stop the violence against the
kids and those people they really need
to stop we need to keep our children
around us as much as possible the
children should bury us we should have
buried there like I said I'm not mad I'm
not angry only things I'm love sad
because I'm gonna miss him I'm gonna
miss he's my oldest son yeah he he took
a piece of my heart with him
but he's gotta live with my heart
forever and I will always pray for him
and I asked everybody to make a prayer
for it and if we're going to worship
something I figured I might as well
worship the Creator instead of any of
the creations now in upon investigating
the villages are member find another
meaning of what Islam is warmuth's
limits those who surrender yourself to
God is a Muslim those who cemento submit
to God God's will Daisy Islam was pure
it was just you just pray to God I am
not afraid to stand alone if allies by
my side I am not afraid to stay alone I
am Not Afraid to saddle
back here on a Dean show we get just got
to interview the buttock a family who
lost their son and it's senseless
violence that overtook them so you get
to reflect this is the test of life
people are dying every day and you see
how they're handling it because they
have faith in the creator of the heavens
and earth but inshallah God willing a
greater good will come from this that
the community that the people will come
together and say we've had enough of
this work with the police to bring this
culprit to justice and the culprit who's
out there who did this the best thing
you can do is turn to the creditor
heavens and earth and repent make
sincere repentance to the crater before
death overtakes you and you mentioned
something about dipping because
otherwise you're going to be dipping
straight into the Hellfire and that's a
scary hot place and then apologize to
this family and go do your time go do
your time because you did the crime and
for those who are out there who are
thinking about being in a gang who are
in a gang this is one of the stupidest
thing that you can do with your life
foolish ignorant families need to work
together to bring their children up
right to stay away stay together work
together so they can bring up solid
families together good institutions of
family so the children aren't without a
father and out without a mother and then
they have enough love in this family so
the kids don't have to go out and look
for love the wrong love somewhere else
joining these gangs joining these
criminal organizations these terrorists
organizations because they're striking
terror into innocent people's homes like
they just did to the Baraka but like a
family so if you have any information to
help solve this crime go ahead and call
the detectives who are on the case work
with the neighborhood watch program work
with the authorities called all demand
also you have his number here to get
everybody involved help clean this
neighborhood up
to help clean this neighborhood up from
these terrorists who are out here the
gang members these are the real
terrorists who are out here terrifying
innocent people so let's work together
let's make dua for this family
supplicate for this family and work
together to bring peace into this
neighborhood and all around the world
and that's what Muslims should be doing
Muslims once was submitted to the will
of God are about peace and bringing
peace not having to the earth and that's
what we want to do by your duas that
allow the Creator to have is that our
sentence tranquility and peace to this
family who's going through such a hard
time allow make it easy and so we can
bring peace into this community that is
being rained with violence day after day
after day so with your help we can do it
God willing work with the authorities
work with the politicians and let's
clean up these streets because that as
the Prophet the last messenger sent to
mankind said if you see an evil change
it with your hands if you're not with
your hands you speak out against it with
your tongue and the least amount of
favors to hate it in your heart and we
hate this senseless violence we hate it
so let's work with the authorities to
put an end to this in our neighborhood
even in your neighborhood if you're not
here in Chicago go ahead and do the
right thing and get involved in the
community to make the community a safer
place for all those people who are
trying to live in peace we'll see you
next time here on the Dean show until
then peace be with you
you